nous vous accueillons aujourd'hui le
journaliste alec castonguay il est chef
du bureau politique au magazine
l'actualité aussi analystes à
radio-canada à la télévision et à la
radio de radio canada
alec castonguay vient de publier aux
éditions québec amérique
un livre intitulé le printemps le plus
long c'est un livre au coeur des
batailles politiques contre la copie
disant je vous montre bien le livre il
n'est pas renversée parce que c'est la
photo qui est juste converser alors
bonjour alec castonguay
bonjour alors à laquelle sont gay dans
votre livre vous affirmez que le système
canadien d' alerte aux pandémies n'a pas
fonctionné pourtant le canada est dotée
d'un réseau mondial de renseignements
sur la santé publique qui est bien
canadien et qui était une référence
mondiale qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
juste
le canada après l'épisode du strass en
2003 puisque toronto avait été frappé
par le strass en 2003 décidé de
renforcer son système d' alerte précoce
donc d'avoir des épidémiologistes des
spécialistes qui travaillent à détecter
un peu partout dans le monde
lorsque de nouvelles maladies
infectieuses apparaissent que ce soit en
asie en afrique ou ailleurs et qui
pourraient potentiellement faire des
ravages chez l'humain et donc on veut
raffiner ce système là c'est un des plus
avancés dans le monde au point où 85
pays de la planète se fie au réseau
canadien d' alerte précoce pour savoir
si un épidémique pourrait être déclenché
quelque part l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms déterminé d'ailleurs que
20% des alertes dans le monde chaque
année venaient du canada ça dit que le
canada était capable de dire voici en
ouganda voici en chinois si ailleurs ce
qui pourrait devenir une pandémie parce
qu'on à détecter des signaux alarmants
de maladies infectieuses et ses soeurs
réseau la de spécialistes qui ne
fonctionnait plus à l'automne 2010 neuf
donc tout juste avant que la pandémie
soit révélée au grand public parce qu'il
y avait des tiraillements internes parce
qu'on a fait des choix politiques qui
étaient dans les dernières années
différents et donc on a un peu atrophiée
ce système là ils étaient moins
efficaces moins performant et il y avait
même arrêté d'émettre des alertes
internationale au moment où la chine
commençait à voir son épidémie à la fin
du mois de décembre 2019 d'ailleurs
c'est ce que vient de confirmer un
rapport qui vient de sortir cette
semaine où apparemment ce réseau il a il
a informé le gouvernement mais ce
n'était pas une alerte formé à troyes où
ça c'est que les spécialistes était
toujours en poste
mais ils ont donc au début de l'épidémie
fait des rapports qui ont été soumis et
donc à la direction santé canada n'a pas
émis d'alerté international donc on n'a
pas participé avec d'autres pays dans le
monde à suivre l'évolution de l'épidémie
pour s'y préparer pour peut-être par
exemple commandé des masques des gants
des blues plus rapidement puisque le
bien des pays qui suivait ça mais dans
tout le bruit vous savez au début d'une
pandémie d'une épidémie énormément de
bruit énormément d'informations qui
circulent qu'est ce qui est vrai qu
est-ce qui est pauvre est où on en est
vraiment c'est quoi l'état de la
recherche donc d'avoir des organismes
comme par exemple ce réseau là au sein
de santé canada qui permet de faire le
tri dans ce qui est important de savoir
est pas important de savoir pour se
préparer
cevital et c'est sur ce réseau au canada
qui était dysfonctionnel dans les
premières semaines de l'épidémie au
début c'est ce qui a été constaté
alors le cours de votre livre se passe
au québec au fond c'est ça donc
est ce que le québec était prêt à cette
pandémie ben non on n'était pas prêt à
cette pandémie comme la plupart des pays
dans le monde occidentaux qui ont été un
peu surpris par
l'éclatement au début du mois de mars en
italie en voyant les qui déborde en
voyant les étangs civis dans les
hôpitaux qui devait faire des choix
entre qui acquit sauvé la vie parce
qu'on manquait de ventilateurs homme en
quête de respirateur artificiel
un peu comme tous les pays ont été
surpris par la virulence au début du
mois de mars alors que dans le fond les
signaux étaient déjà là bas on les a
pris un peu à la légère
comme la plupart des pays riches et
occidentaux on se disait ça vient de
chine ça vient de loin c'est pas la
première fois qu'on a des maladies
infectieuses qui viennent d'asie qui se
rendent pas jusque chez nous donc on
s'est préparés mais très tranquillement
en se disant en réalité ça arrivera
probablement pas et ont été frappés
comme la plupart des autres pays
occidentaux
lors du printemps regardez pour une
audience internationale
on a du mal à imaginer qu'une province
comme le québec n'est pas de plan pour
une éventuelle pandémie est ce que ces
plans n'existait pas du tout oui ce qui
n'a pas été actionnés vous qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il y a un plan il ya un plan
qui avait été élaboré en 2006 par un
gouvernement qui n'est plus au pouvoir
maintenant mais qu'il est même très
élaborée qui fait plus de 140 pages qui
dit ben voici lorsqu'on a une pandémie
respiratoires pandémie d'influenza voici
ce qu'il faut faire étape 1 étape deux
étapes 3 voici combien de membres du
personnel de la santé vont tomber malade
tousse et consignés dans un plan de 2006
mais qui n'a pas été actualisée dans les
15 dernières années dont la plupart des
gestionnaires du réseau de la santé
maintenant puisque évidemment l'airé
gestionnaire change ne l'avez pas lu ou
était même pas au courant qu'il existait
alors on a assez peu utilisée qu on l'a
voulu le mettre à jour à la mi-février
il était déjà très tard oms a pris ou
plusieurs semaines avant de le mettre à
jour donc en a été frappée au début du
mois de mars le plan de 2006 est un plan
qui avait même pas été mise à jour par
rapport à toutes les réformes des terres
bt fait d'un milieu de la santé alors il
était il était lui aussi utile que si on
l'avait mis à jour à chaque année on en
avait fait vraiment une bible pour
savoir comment se comporter en temps de
pandémie
donc on avait un plan il existait il
n'était pas à jour donc on n'a pas pu
vraiment l'utiliser et à faire en sorte
qu'on a été un peu pris par surprise
et puis il ya eu la décision de 32 de
fermer le d'interdire le parti
plus si on prend le cas des masques 1,95
leurs exportations commencent à et
l'impact de ces décisions sur le québec
et le canada
ben écoutez le fait que donald trump a
été à la maison blanche pendant le début
de cette épidémie la eu beaucoup de
conséquences
beaucoup de conséquences pour le canada
beaucoup de conséquences pour le reste
de la planète parce que tantôt on
parlait du réseau un canadien de
surveillance des maladies infectieuses
qui ne fonctionnait pas mais donald
trump aussi atrophiée son propre réseau
de surveillance américain vous savez les
centres pour le contrôle des maladies
infectieuses des fameux cdc américains
en poste des employés en chine parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de maladies
qui viennent de chine
mais par exemple le poste d'observateur
à yoann en chine n'avait pas été
remplacés depuis que donald trump était
à la maison blanche donc on avait
personne dans cette ville là où
l'épidémie a commencé on avait coupé la
moitié de l'équipe en poste à pékin et à
shanghai donc on avait beaucoup moins de
spécialistes en chine pour analyser le
l'information donc il à lui parce qu'il
est en bataille contre la chine parce
qu'il voulait punir la chine pour des
raisons économiques ne pas avoir placé
les postes là donc même les américains
n'ont pas pu mondialement tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé comme le canada a pu
le faire bref ça a été un autre échec de
plus ici nous par rapport à la situation
canadienne c'est clair que d'avoir un
président à l'époque imprévisible au sud
de la frontière qui par exemple
effectivement décide de garder tous les
masques n95 sur son territoire c'est eux
qui nous approvisionnent en plus grande
quantité habituellement sa force et une
bataille diplomatique est clair de
plusieurs jours le canada les états-unis
pour les convaincre de nous laisser
recevront ces masculins qui sont très
importants pour les travailleurs de la
santé mais il y avait aussi toutes
sortes de conséquences possibles qui
offrait lui valurent ils ne se sont pas
matérialisées mais par exemple de nature
comme la frontière à l'exportation de
fruits et de légumes par exemple parce
qu'il décide que la sécurité alimentaire
des états unis près mais qui garde tous
les aliments aux états unis ben
évidemment canada il fait froid au mois
de mars
on fait pas pousser nous mêmes aux
fruits et aux légumes donc qu'est-ce
qu'on se retrouve avec un pénuries
d'aliments tous ces scénarios ont été
évoqués dans les hautes sphères du
gouvernement du québec en trop d'enfants
qui ont nourri notre population commence
donald trump empêche la nourriture de
passer ou s'ils empêchent d'autres
méditent d'autres équipements médicaux
de se rendre au canada
là je parle des masques n95
quand il atteint le fameux respirateur
artificiel 50 % viennent des états unis
alors si on en a besoin en urgence et
que décident les garder parce qu'ils en
ont besoin et on fait quoi alors oui ça
a été un printemps où la relation avec
les états unis qui était déjà pas simple
sur donald trump s'est c'est vraiment
complexifier le pendant quelques mois
vous vous avez eu un accès privilégié
aux fonctionnaires de l'état québécois
est-ce que c'était facile de les
convaincre de parler en même temps
généralement ça vient avec
avec un côté spin doctor 1 connaît un
côté d'horreur d'image risque quand vous
avez pu éviter ce jeu là je sais que
vous êtes expérimenté mais quand même on
voudrait bien vous écouter sur sa
demande comment j'ai pu les convaincre
à ma grande surprise ils ont accepté
parce que les hauts fonctionnaires les
sous ministres sous ministres adjoints
ou secrétaire général du gouvernement
qui les plus hauts fonctionnaires ne
parle généralement pas aux journalistes
encore moins en pleine crise alors je
demande évidemment alors parlé d'un
ex-élu qui sont aux commandes de l'état
et j'ai pu avoir leur histoire comment
ça s'était passé dans la crise pour eux
je les demande et en ailleurs quand même
peu d'espoir ils ont ma foi accepté tous
aucune des demandes que je fête n'a été
refusé je pense que vous voulez
témoigner de ce qu'ils avaient vécu qui
était exceptionnel sachant que ça se
représentera peut-être pendant des
décennies ce type de gestion de pandémie
la laissait donc un héritage à ceux qui
vont peut-être avoir à en affronter une
éventuellement donc raconter leur voler
leurs difficultés leurs bons coups pour
que ça serve un peu de manuels de pour
une gestion de crises éventuelles
aussi je les ai convaincus lorsque je
leur ai dit on peut attendre quatre ou
cinq ans pour faire ce post mortem le
mans n'aura jamais les émotions vous
venez de vie moi j'ai fait beaucoup mais
entrevue entre les deux vagues pendant
l'été c'était donc encore frais à leur
mémoire qu'est ce qui s'était passé le
12 mars ou pas ce qui s'était passé le
10 avril il senti les gars pas de
raconter comment ils se sont sentis et
ce qu'ils étaient craintifs panique est
dépourvu heureux alors que dans cinq ans
les émotions cette gamme un peu et
disparaissent moi je voulais qu à un
côté humain aux livres pour qu'on sente
comment il avait vécu cette tragédie là
en haut lieu donc ils ont tous accepté
comme on contourne cette idée qu'ils
vont évidemment me raconter seulement le
bon côté des choses
de fait qu'ils acceptent en très grand
nombre de parler en sorte qu'ils savent
bien que je vais parler à d'autres est
longue il ya un effet l'aude
si on en vient sur le forum tu peux pas
mentir suspect
et que d'autres vont raconter son
histoire et l'a peut-être que ça va
entrer en contradiction avec votre
histoire si c'est pas tout à fait la
réalité vous avez raconté et donc le
fait d'en avoir beaucoup fait en sorte
comme on est le casse-tête sur place
alors question ce qui a eu deux
personnes c'est vrai qu'un risque tant
des rendus à 50 personnes comme c'est le
cas de mme ont réussi à un moment donné
ça s'équilibre
l'autre façon de travailler c'est que
j'ai obtenu beaucoup de documents sont à
la loi d'accès à l'information sur les
documents que j'ai demandé que j'ai
obtenus pour être capable de raconter un
peu par exemple des échanges de
l'immeuble de messages des procès
verbaux de réunions au ministère de la
santé ça fait en sorte que ça annule un
peu parce qu'évidemment j'avais des
documents pour l'ordre et ben vous voyez
c'est ce qui s'est passé le procès
verbal du 22 janvier dit que et que tu y
as parlé puis voici ce qu'il a dit alors
le salir mais dans l'est dans l'esprit
puis césar oui c'est vrai alors qu'ils
savent que j'ai des documents et
intérêts le mode histoire alors ça tout
ça mais ça c'est les méthodes
journalistiques assez classique
où on réussit à à contrer un peu cet
effet de d'embellissement est ce que ces
parfums probablement pas lui-même aime
généralement raconter quand même le bon
côté des choses mais ça neutralisent
quand même les effets les plus
importants alors c'est un livre qui est
écrit donc lui qui a été écrit dans
l'urgence en plein de premières vagues
peut-on s'attendre à une ou deux suites
puisque nous avons eu la deuxième vague
est peut-être ben on n'espère pas
peut-être une troisième vague
beaucoup de gens me demandent s'il va
avoir un tome 2 parce qu'ils ont aimé le
tome 1 qui vient de sortir
la réponse courte pour laisse penser que
ce n'est pas dans mes intentions pas
dire que je vais changer d'idée
éventuellement pourquoi ce n'est pas
dans mes intentions
parce que oui la deuxième vague a été
importante mais d'un point de vue
gouvernemental décision à prendre
le gros choc c'est la première vague
l'adaptation du gouvernement quelque
chose qui ne connaît pas c'est vraiment
il plus intéressant à raconter dans une
gestion qui est la deuxième oui on a été
en confinement il a fallu changer les
choses mais grosso modo cette adaptation
sur un même thème on savait que
lorsqu'on arrive à un certain nombre de
corps dont on ferme les restaurants où
l'on ferme les gymnastes alors la
surprise était pas la même et donc les
meilleurs les choix déchirants n'étaient
pas les mêmes au gouvernement
avait déjà passé par là on serait un peu
se tait les faits allait donner le
confinement parce qu'on l'avait déjà
vécu la première fois alors l'aspect
narratif dramatique de la deuxième vague
est beaucoup moins intéressant que le
premier aspect je trouve avec celui du
printemps ou le tu avais le choc est ce
que ça veut dire qu'un jour je décrirai
pas là dessus
peut-être je veux obtenir des documents
peut-être que les procès verbaux des
réunions du conseil des ministres dans
vos lecteurs vont être extrêmement
intéressant mais pour l'instant les gens
trouveraient que la tombe de et pâle un
peu par rapport au temps oui juste parce
qu'il n'était plus au courant de virus
on connaissait mieux on savait comment
réagir si ça minimise pas la difficulté
de la deuxième vague mais c'était
complètement différent de la première je
trouve qu avait plus d'intérêt à
raconter la première alors pour
l'instant y'a pas de tombe de en marche
mais bon faut jamais dire jamais il y
aura peut-être une suite mais sous une
autre forme
mercer avec exactement merci merci à la
casse tanguay je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et vous venez de publier aux
éditions québec amérique qu un livre
intitulé le printemps le plus long c'est
un livre qui est record des batailles
politiques contrat qu'on me dise merci
pour d'avoir accepté l'invitation
ça m'a fait plaisir à voir